we know the stars are all about that
fountain of youth our lauren
zima learned the ways to treat yourself
from the comfort of your own home
liz we know celebrities will go all out
for skin care i mean we have covered
vampire facials
mono threading even bee sting therapy
but what are some of your beauty secrets
that we can do at home that won't break
the bank
i love taking a facial oil mixed with a
very very thick moisturizer
i rub them together i create a mask on
my face
and then while i'm watching netflix let
it sit for 30 minutes my skin is just
super hydrated and glowy it's netflix
and chill for your skin literally
i wanted to ask you about this i've seen
it online what is
slugging slugging is one of my favorite
techniques
so what you do is you take a little bit
of petroleum jelly after you've done
your entire skincare routine
you just apply it on in a thin layer and
you wake up with the most
hydrated soft skin we teamed up with
beauty expert liz kennedy and
rock skin care for ways to help keep
your skin looking youthful
and revived so products are key what's
one of your favorites
i am absolutely obsessed with rock's
revive and glow serum with vitamin c
what makes this different rock conducted
a clinical study on 31 women and every
single person who used this product
had firmer more luminous skin in just
four weeks
the best part is you can purchase it at
target for under 25 dollars
you